they could exist these oceans what has
been seen well what the astronomers have
seen is they've actually been studying
the atmosphere of this white dwarf star
what they've seen is kind of like the
debris that's been left over they think
from these asteroids going into the star
so this is one of these interesting
things that we can do with telescopes
modern telescopes now is rather than
actually directly observe the asteroid
themselves and we can actually see the
signs of them by looking at the light
from this star so it's a very
interesting study okay and you better
take us through our dwarves what's the
difference between a white one a red one
and a black one if there is such a thing
yes so our what a white dwarf is it's
kind of almost like a vision of what our
son will become in a few billion years
time so when a sun-like star begins to
near the end of its life it begins to
sort of shed its atmosphere and slowly
but surely it's very hot cords exposed
and that core has contracted and it's
tremendously hot emitting a lot of UV
radiation it's about a hundred thousand
degrees Celsius and that is what we call
a white dwarf star and so well the
astronomers have done is they've
actually used a telescope on the palmer
in the Canary Islands to look at the
light from That star and in it they've
seen the sort of chemical fingerprints
of in this case it was oxygen and
hydrogen and a few other what we call
metals heavier elements that have sort
of given this a hint that perhaps maybe
there's a debris from an asteroid in the
atmosphere of that white dwarf star okay
they might have water on it why do we
think that it was comets or asteroids
that bought water to earth well this is
the interesting thing we're slowly
piecing together how we think our own
solar system formed and how we think
planets like the earth formed and in
fact we've learned a lot from studying
our own solar system you know we visited
the comets and asteroids in our own
solar system but one of the interesting
things I think about this study is
actually it's very indicative of
something we've also been doing and
that's learning about our own solar
system's history through studying other
solar systems so for a long time we
thought that asteroids and comets were
the Water Bearers because they're very
cold the very i see'em we think that
perhaps actually now that evidence
suggests that it was the asteroids
rather than the comets which historic
we thought brought the water but here in
this in this particular study we
actually see these signs that yes there
must have been a water-rich asteroid and
in this particular solar system to
deposit this material in the start and
so maybe this process of you know Walter
being delivered to planets by asteroids
maybe it's common throughout our galaxy
okay and we regard water as a
pre-requisite for some form of human
life but are we being too kind of Earth
centric so to speak isn't there the
possibility if there are life forms out
there that they're beyond our
imagination and they don't need water oh
absolutely i mean this is that this is
one of the the great questions in
astrobiology you know is the life that
we're looking for are we sort of really
looking along a very narrow field of
view we think like you see that water is
very important in life but also we found
in our studies of these alien worlds
these extrasolar planets around other
stars we found other things that we
think are needed for life so in some
atmospheres of some exoplanets we've
seen what are called organic compound so
things that contain carbon things like
carbon dioxide and methane so all these
all these studies are slowly showing
this that perhaps our galaxy is full of
the ingredients of life as we know it
okay well where do you stand on this the
thorny issue i know it's much debated if
there is intelligent or super
intelligent life out there should we try
and get in touch or keep a low profile
well my personal view is that we should
probably keep our heads low I'm not so
keen on communicating out into the
galaxy because we don't know who's out
there and I think that that could be
quite a risky sort of proposition sort
of broadcasting your location that's not
always have been a good thing to do on
earth and I don't think it's a very good
thing to do in the Milky Way either